les diasporas africaines du nord comme
du sud de ça sont impactés par les
évolutions socio économique du continent
africain sûrement parce qu'elles
influent la perception qu'on a d'elle en
europe est ce que cette diaspora doit
s'impliquer dans les dynamiques
géopolitique du continent africain
je pense que oui mais encore une fois il
ne ce n'est pas simplement une réflexion
que doit être portée par la diaspora
c'est par tout le monde c'est à dire en
fait nous vivons sur cette terre et je
pense que chacun de nous nous devons
aussi essayer de questionner les
déséquilibres qui lie à dans le monde
pour que chaque être humain puisse vivre
le mieux possible ça me paraît être
essentielle et c'est pas simplement
parce que moi je me sens faisant partie
de la diaspora africaine bien que je
pense que la réalité que chacun de nous
peu importe leur couleur de peau nous
faisons partie de la diaspora africaine
si on remonte dans le temps suffisamment
loin avec exactement mais en fait les
gens très souvent renvoie la diaspora
africaine sur une couleur de peau ou sur
une histoire très récente mais je pense
que c'est la réflexion c'est sur la
place de l'humain
sur cette terre est ce qu'il est
possible d'accepter
autant de déséquilibre entre les
continents est ce qu'il est possible
d'accepter autant de déséquilibres au
sein de son propre pays
je pense que c'est pas juste
je vais citer un rappeur qui s'appelle
nac mendoza dans un morceau qui
s'appelle tout le monde s'en fout
l'ancien ring qui
qui dit on va vous rendre château d'eau
mais libéré le cfr est-ce qu'on peut
sérieusement parler d'une france
postcoloniale alors que le franc cfa est
encore là et que sa défense si on s'en
réfère aux emails d'hillary clinton a
révélé récemment par wikileaks justifie
la destruction d'un pays comme la libye
par la france
bah écoutez ce qui est très bien dans le
rap c'est que ça peut nous emmener à
nous questionner sur la société dans
laquelle nous vivons
effectivement je pense que lorsque vous
discuté un peu avec les gens de la rue
on va dire
mais en fait ils ne savent pas que le
franc cfa est fabriqué en france par
exemple
et je le redis imaginez vous un instant
que l'euro serait fabriqué par exemple
en chine est-ce que vous pensez que ce
serait normal évidemment ils vous
répondent que non et
lorsqu'on parle de la colonisation c'est
avant tout on parle d'une domination et
effectivement je pense que la réflexion
autour du sort du franc cfa montre
vraiment cette domination parce que si
quelqu'un détient votre portefeuille si
quelqu'un détient votre argent c'est
compliqué pour vous il suffit de voir
les impacts sur l'agriculture en afrique
typiquement pour voir à quel point le
franc cfa est une forme moderne de
colonisation elle avait totalement mais
c'est ce qui est intéressant c'est que
la plupart des gens ne le savent pas et
dans les médias on n'en parle pas
d'ailleurs il y à des intellectuels
africains qui dénonce depuis très
longtemps ce système de domination de la
france sur les pays qui utilisent le
franc cfa est donc je pense que si notre
pays veut vraiment aider
le continent africain c'est déjà faire
en sorte que ces pays puissent être
autonomes au niveau financier
les médians pas plus parlé finalement
d'un des moteurs de la guerre qu'on a
menées en libye qui étaient très
clairement de mettre fin à un projet de
kadhafi de remplacer le franc cfa par
une monnaie panafricaine effectivement
je crois que très souvent on nous
explique pas les vrais comment je
pourrais dire ça les vraies raisons des
guerres mais ça c'est depuis la nuit des
temps c'est pour cela qu'il faut
toujours essayer de comprendre le
pourquoi des choses
on va passer à des questions sur le
racisme plus spécifiquement en france
quand macron avouer un crime contre
l'humanité en évoquant la guerre
d'algérie est ce qui est ce que c'est
une voie vers un apaisement ou est ce
que c'est une fracture supplémentaires
au sein de la société française
pour moi c'est c'est dire la vérité tout
simplement et dire la vérité peut-être
que ça fait mal au début mais il est
important de connaître la vérité ça me
paraît essentiel de dire que ça a été un
crime contre l'humanité comme a été un
crime contre l'humanité le fait qu'on
l'ait tué tant de millions d'amérindiens
lorsque christophe colomb est arrivé
dans les amériques de toute façon vous
ne pouvez pas avoir de crime contre
l'humanité
lorsque vous voulez dominer d'autres
peuples parce que ça se fait dans la
violence obligatoirement donc la
colonisation oui ces crimes contre
l'humanité c'est une évidence
sinon comment vous voulez que les autres
la population en question se soumettent
donc il faut violente et cette
population il faut montrer votre force
et votre détermination pour que les
autres restent tranquilles et accepte
cette domination donc oui qu'une contre
l'humanité il faut en parler il faut
analyser les choses pour que puisse
peut-être
dépasser les préjugés qui existent parce
que je pense que il ya des
incompréhensions parce que
on n'a pas le courage d'affronter les
réalités de l'histoire et vous pensez de
cette déclaration de macron va
contribuer à une forme d'apaisement en
france je pense que oui il faudrait
qu'il continue dans ce sur ce chemin là
parce que il me semble je crois je sais
pas s'il était parvenu en arrière
d'ailleurs en disant que peut-être que
il avait un peu tempérer les choses
je pense qu'il faut pas tempéré il faut
juste dire la vérité je pense
qu'effectivement c'est un choc au départ
parce que les gens n'ont pas l'habitude
n'ont pas été éduqués à comprendre
vraiment ce que ça a été la colonisation
donc il faut leur expliquer
je reste persuadé qu' il est préférable
d'avancer dans la vérité
parlons un instant ce festival afro
féministe ni à sa peau au cours duquel
certains espaces étaient réservées aux
femmes noires et métisses et qui a fait
réagir et anne hidalgo récemment le fait
qu'une responsable socialiste ainsi que
la licra relate relais une fake news un
festival qui serait totalement interdit
aux blancs lancé par va les rendre un
jeu ce qui était la tête de liste fn aux
dernières élections régionales en île de
france ça vous inspire quoi
ça m'inspire que nous sommes dans un
monde d'immédiateté et qu'il faut réagir
immédiatement et ne pas
chercher la véracité de l'information
même qu'on ait un dirigeant politique de
première envergure baisse et le canon
une fois que c'est le cas donc on est
dans ce monde là c'est en fait
parfois on ne vérifie pas la source on
ne vérifie pas la formation est donc on
peut faire on fait on peut faire
beaucoup d'erreurs dans ce cas là mais
moi je pense quand même dedans dans
cette situation là moi je suis pour que
l'on ouvre les débats à toutes les
personnes et de toutes les couleurs je
pense qu'on doit discuter librement de
tout et donc on peut inviter des
personnes de couleur différente et dire
ce qu'on a à dire
pendant l'émancipation des femmes or aux
usa comme en france est passé par des
mouvements prônant la non mixité je
prends soin mlf au lendemain de mai 68
où beaucoup plus récemment au cours de
nuit debout pourquoi une féministe comme
anne hidalgo qui a hérité des bénéfices
d'intel militantisme leur fusse-t-elle
noir
parce que peut-être qu'elle ne comprend
pas exactement le pourquoi parce que
c'est pas questionner
peut-être que cela choque
de savoir que tout d'un coup
peut-être qu'on accepte moins volontiers
des personnes blanches dans une réunion
moi je peux comprendre qu'on soit
choquée moi je peux comprendre que dans
le passé effectivement et du et ses
mouvements d'un évidemment moi je suis
encore une fois je comprends la démarche
mais je pense que la démarche encore
plus forte lorsque vous inviter des
personnes d'horizons différents et
qu'ils entendent votre discours pour les
éduquer à eux aussi
est ce que vous pensez pas que cette
forme particulière de féminise que porte
anne hidalgo contribuer à installer une
forme de racisme politiquement correct à
gauche
quelle forme de féminisme cette forme
qui s'appuie sur les sort seulement la
laïcité qu'on a vu émerger de façon très
prégnante lors du dernier quinquennat
je ne sais pas parce qu'en fait je ne
sais pas exactement comment elle qu'on
se voilent le féminisme d'abidal donc si
je pourrai pas vous répondre je pense
qu'effectivement il faut écouter tous
les courants d'accord on peut ne pas
être d'accord avec certains courants
mais encore une fois je pense pour ma
part que les femmes noires effectivement
il ya une spécificité d'être femme et
noire mais aussi il faut que ces femmes
noires le fasse entendre aussi aux
femmes de couleur blanche ou d'autres
dit entre nous parce qu'il ya en fait
les couleurs n'existe pas vraiment il ya
personne de blandy de noir donc aux deux
personnes d'autres origines il faut
qu'ils entendent ce discours pour qu'ils
puissent être éduqués
parce qu'en fait lorsque vous êtes
je pense de couleur blanche parfois
vous ne maîtrisez pas certaines choses
par exemple vous ne comprenez pas que
l'espace public n'est pas vécue de la
même façon selon votre couleur de peau
ok ça c'est mais il faut que quelqu'un
vous le dise c'est pour ça que je trouve
que c'est intéressant de faire
participer les gens et peu importe leur
couleur pour qu'ils puissent entendre et
pour qu'ils soient éduqués de leur côté
parce que si vous vous parlez en que en
tant que personnes noires bain
effectivement vous n'allez pas éduquer
les autres à comprendre ce qui se passe
et moi je suis pour l'éducation de tout
le monde en même temps interdire un
espace aux blancs c'est une excellente
façon de faire réaliser ce que c'est que
la ségrégation dans un espace public
pour des blancs qui n'y sont pas du tout
habitués ça c'est un autre débat
sans ça je trouve ça très intéressant
d'ailleurs je pensais qu'en fait c'était
de la provocation pour faire comprendre
qu'est ce que c'était est cité s'est
grillé qu'est-ce que c'était être blanc
c'était pour moi c'était en fait une
façon d'interpeller les gens et ça je
trouvais ça très intéressant donc je ne
sais pas si c'était vraiment ça mais je
trouve qu'effectivement le fait tout
d'un coup d'interdire permet de prendre
conscience
d'ailleurs il ya une expérience qui
était fait aux états unis non c'était je
crois que c'est au canada avec les yeux
bleus pour que les enfants apprennent à
sentir dans leur peau le racisme je sais
pas si vous connaissez cette histoire en
fait il est le prof
qui avait inventé une histoire en disant
voilà que les les
les scientifiques disent que lorsque
vous avez des yeux bleus vous est
beaucoup plus intelligent et donc tout
d'un coup les enfants qui veulent
essayer bleus se sentait supérieur le
lendemain il y avait des enfants qui
étaient arrivés avec des lunettes parce
qu'il n'avait pas les yeux bleus et je
crois que la prof quelques jours après
avait dit ouais j'ai bien réfléchi je
crois je me suis trompé c'est l inverse
est donc en fait les enfants avaient
senti à un moment donné dans leur corps
l'injustice d'être jugé à travers les
couleurs de deux yeux et donc c'était
c'est pour ça que je pensais que le fait
d'annoncer que c'était interdit aux
personnes de couleur blanche étaient
pour justement qu'ils puissent sentir
dans leur corps tout d'un coup être
rejeté et donc prendre conscience de la
gravité de leurs jugements parfois sur
les personnes de couleur différente en
l'occurrence je crois pas je crois que
ça s'inscrive est vraiment dans une
tradition militante de non mixité qui
remonte à pas mal de temps c'est au tout
début des années 70 c'était quelque
chose d'assez courant en particulier
chez les féministes de tenir réunion et
d'interdire ces réunions nous sommes et
c'est l'une des bases qui a fait le
féminisme aujourd'hui et surtout
l'émancipation des femmes si tant est
qu'elle soit émancipe aujourd'hui encore
énormément d'inégalités mais en tout cas
les progrès qui ont été réalisés ces
quarante dernières années se sont basé
en partie sur ce concept militants de
non mixité et cela qu'on assiste et là
c'est la même chose appliquée aux femmes
noires oui bien évidemment de toute
façon on va on pourrait remonter plus
loin parce qu'il ya eu pas mal de lieux
qui étaient interdites aux fans aussi
que c'était que les hommes
encore aujourd'hui d'ailleurs
la construction des banlieues françaises
par strates qui sont éthiquement assez
homogène au fur et à mesure des des
vagues migratoires de l'après guerre at
il construit une société française
communautariser à l'américaine est-ce
qu'il est temps de regarder ça en face
ou est ce qu'on continue à s'aveugler
sur l'idée d'une république une et
indivisible blanc
bon ce qui est sûr c'est que ça a été
une volonté politique
ok
moi j'ai eu la chance de grandir dans
des cités où est-ce qu'ils avaient
encore une très grande mixité de
personnes que ce soit au niveau des
religions des couleurs de peau dit
niveau social aussi
effectivement aujourd'hui on voit que
c'est assez dramatique mais est ce que
pour cela ça construit une communauté je
pense parce que ça construit des
communautés c'est à dire que de
l'extérieur les gens les regardent comme
étant des communautés mais ce serait des
communautés basé sur quoi
sur des originalités qui est dans la
situation actuelle à la france sur des
pratiques religieuses
donc ce serait des communes et
communautés sur l'ethnie qu'est ce que
vous entendez par ethnie
j'entends par pays d'origine plus qu'à
tenir parce qu'effectivement si on va
regarder très précisément les différents
pays d'afrique on sait bien que les
frontières sont loin de représenter les
groupes ethniques
malgré tout on a quand même une très
grande homogénéité
à la fois social mais également
ethniques et religieuses dans les
banlieues françaises qui s'aggrave avec
le temps on a une véritable construction
sur une base organistique de quelque
chose qui est très concrètement donne de
racisme oui ça rabaisse a alors je suis
d'accord avec vous parce qu'en fait la
question c'est sur la notion de
communauté c'est ce qui me qui
m'interpelle parce que très souvent on
parle d'une communauté noire on parle
d'une communauté musulmane et qui
n'existe pas vraiment c'est clair
qu'entre les camerounais et martiniquais
ok d'accord c'est pour ça que je veux
juste qu'on soit d'accord sur ça on est
d'accord
effectivement ça renforce l'idée
du racisme bien évidemment et surtout en
fait ce qui est assez dramatique c'est
que on regroupe des personnes qui ont
presque le même niveau social c'est à
dire que c'est ça le danger est aussi on
les stigmatise c'est à dire que tout
d'un coup tout ce qui est négatif en
france viendrait de ses banlieues là et
le regard négatif qu'on porte sur ses
enfants à eybens ne leur permettent pas
de construire une entité forte et
sereine parce que très souvent je vais
dans les haies dans certaines écoles où
les enfants ont du mal à se situer comme
français ou française et ça c'est
extrêmement dramatique tout d'abord
effectivement parce qu'ils ressentent le
rejet de la société et aussi après il ya
aussi ce que le fruit de loyauté
vis-à-vis des parents est donc
effectivement je pense qu'il faut il
faut avoir une autre démarche des
politiques je pense une démarche
extrêmement négatif parce qu'en fait
très souvent ils renvoient une image
très négative sur sur ses lieux de vie
et donc on avait une construction au
sens urbain du racisme âgé de 40 ans
sans que non seulement avec une
participation générale tous les
politiques de tous bords mais avec un
entretien tout ça à travers la politique
de la ville mais parce que effectivement
je pense parce que j'en avais discuté un
jour avec
des des politiques
et c'était assez
déstabilisant
parce que en fait ils comprenaient pas
le discours que l'on peut tenir là il
était persuadé que les gens seraient
heureux ensemble il y avait une grande
hutte de pied de le grand plan urbain
qui ont donné ces villes qui sont
aujourd'hui totalement déshumanisé oui
j'ai coupé de ce qui est grave c'est que
j'en ai parlé il n'y a pas très
longtemps avec eux et comprennent
toujours pas non faut dire que c'est pas
évident à voir depuis le xvième
arrondissement peut-être mais c'est vrai
que c'est dramatique
vous dites que la mixité présente dans
le football doit être présente dans tous
les autres pans de la cité française est
ce que vous pensez qu'il faut en passer
par la discrimination positive en france
et dans quels cas est-ce qu'on parlerait
d'une discrimination positive social
comme on pratique à sciences po par
exemple ou d'une discrimination sur une
base ethnique qui est jusqu'ici
totalement illégal en france mais qui se
pratique depuis déjà plusieurs décennies
aux états unis de toute façon je pense
que si vous faites une discrimination
positif sur
le social ça revient beaucoup à faire
une
une proposition qui sur l'ethnie parce
qu'effectivement dans nos dans nos
banlieues ce qu'on vient de parler très
souvent en grande majorité ce sont des
personnes non blanches
ça recoupe on va dire pour pour être
enseignant à sciences po glee c'est
clair mais c'est pas tout à fait la même
chose il ya une certaine hypocrisie
du président de ahd assimilés classes
sociales et
grâce aux quais moi je pense que pour
moi en tout cas il est évident
qu'il faut favoriser les choses et pour
favoriser
la mixité sur la couleur de peau ou la
mixité sur le niveau social il faut
faire des quotas moi ça me paraît
important
parce qu'on a fait on l'a fait aussi
pour les femmes c'est à dire qu'à un
moment donné on a décidé qu'il y aurait
parité donc ça veut dire c'est une
volonté et moi je pense qu'effectivement
nous devons aussi affronter ces
problèmes là et dont vous êtes pour
discrimination positive sur des bases
ethniques et pas seulement sur des bases
sociales comme je vous ai dit sur les
deux sur la base ethnique et sociale
parce que effectivement il ya aussi une
réalité mais je crois qu'il serait
important par exemple
de faire en sorte de peut-être mettre
beaucoup plus de moyens
sur
l'éducation pour les personnes les plus
pauvres dans notre société
parce que peut-être qu'ils auraient plus
de facilité à réussir
et après dans des lieux on devrait
obliger
certains
groupes médias ou d'autres
à embaucher certaines personnes qu'il ya
un quota réservé
parce que comme ça on peut on va faire
changer l'imaginaire pourquoi parce qu
il ya d iliad et il ya des fois on va
déboule dans des endroits où je me dis
mais c'est marrant quand même ça dérange
personne vous arrivez peut-être qu'il ya
cinq ans personne qui travaille dans ce
lieu là et il n'y a il n'y a pas de
mixité liées à la couleur de la peau et
je reste persuadé que les personnes qui
travaillent ne font pas attention ça ne
les dérange en fait j'ai pratiquement
pour les blancs et son aperçoivent pas
oui
et je dis tiens c'est bizarre que les
gens ça les dérange pas et vous disent
oui mais on a cherché non je pense pas
que vous ayez cherchez pas ce que vous
voyez pas en fait
comment est-ce que vous résoudrez les
discrimination systémique al embauche au
logement à l'orientation scolaire au
crédit bancaire et plein d'autres choses
et comment vous analyser l'évolution des
mesures gouvernementales
sur ces questions
écoutez c'est une question compliquée
comment je pourrais faire
comprenez des ponts vue là parce que
j'ai jamais réfléchir à savoir comment
je pourrais pourriez terminé ministre
parlait tant pis pour trouver même pas
sûr si vous êtes mini je suis pas sûr
que un ministre peut arriver à faire
changer les choses mais en fait il
faudrait qu'il ya une réelle volonté
une réelle volonté et je pense qu'il ya
pas une réelle volonté parce que la
grande majorité des personnes qui
réfléchissent à ces sujets ne sont pas
touchés en fait on va re cela ou n'ont
pas de familles qui sont touchées par
cela et parfois même il y en a pire qui
pensent que ça n'existe pas vraiment en
fait là aussi j'ai déjà discuté avec eux
des politiques parfois ils sont ils te
disent oui mais ça existe vraiment le
racisme en france vous croyez que parce
que vous avez une certaine couleur
origines c'est plus difficile pour vous
là où vous êtes athée recquois c'est
passionnant d'être déconnecté à ce point
et ouais et donc en fait pour réfléchir
et trouver les solutions
effectivement voilà pourquoi peut-être
qu'il faut des quotas qui seraient liées
à la couleur et aux origines pour qu'ils
aient plus de mixité de pensée sur la
société française
mais c'est vrai trouvé la solution jeu
c'est difficile
préparez vous parce que ministériel peut
vous tomber raide quand vous avez vu que
j'étais pas préparé donc je vais me
préparer
comment est ce qu'on peut se saisir du
problème du racisme dans un pays qui
interdit les statistiques ethniques
c'est à peu près aussi idiot que
d'interdire un usage du thermomètre en
effet
c'est vrai qu effectivement je pense que
la première des choses pour
pour avancer pour comprendre un problème
c'est l'évaluation et effectivement ça
c'est un truc je ne comprends pas bien
sûr qu'il faut faire des statistiques
parce que quand vous aurez des
statistiques devant vous mais vous
n'allez pas pouvoir nier les choses ce
qui sera intéressant c'est savoir
le pourcentage
de personnes
non blanches
à l'assemblée nationale ce sera
intéressant parce que si vous avez un
pourcentage ça va être très vite fait 1
allez-y dites moi ça en dehors de
taubira qu'est ce qu'on à
la personne la baisse serait due 100%
c'est ça alors ça serait bien en dessous
de 1% nettement entre damien en fait il
faut pas parler de 2 les personnes qui
sont en minorité faut parler des gens
qui sont en majorité donc ça veut dire
que ça ferait 99% très largement 99 %
exactement donc les 99% sont beaucoup
plus parlant que les 1% tout à fait et
d'un qu'on pourrait faire ça aussi dans
d'autres domaines pour voir le
pourcentage d'hommes qu'il y a et le
pourcentage de femmes et là on verrait
on peut ça c'est légal et ça ce sera
intéressant et ça donne déjà des
résultats qui sont pas très joli à voir
elle exactement parce que très souvent
on parle on parle pas en fait de ceux
qui sont dominants et je pense qu'il
faut pointer du doigt ceux qui sont
dominants disant tiens à 99 % d'hommes
quand même
si vous dites 1% ils vont dire ah ouais
il faudrait peut-être qu'on arrive à 2%
ce serait bien
je vais je vais citer à nouveau un
rappeur un booba qui dans ma définition
pose ses rimes je voulais savoir
pourquoi l'afrique vit mal m'en du cp à
la seconde il me parle de la joconde et
des allemands
l'éducation nationale est également les
arts et la culture en france ont-ils
échoué à faire prendre conscience à la
population blanche de son passé colonial
et esclavagiste
ou est ce qu'on cherche tout simplement
à cacher la poussière sous le tapis de
l'histoire officielle
j'ai l'impression qu'ils y pensent même
pas
je me pas sûr que ce soit un complot en
fait c'est à dire que j'ai l'impression
que les autres n'existent pas
en fait
je trouve très souvent dans les écoles
et je demande aux enfants
qui est christophe colomb et donc les
enfants me répondent toujours c'est
celui qui a découvert l'amérique je leur
dis ah bon
je relise enfin écoutés imaginons nous
sommes dans cette classe il ya quelqu'un
qui vous la porte qui dit j'ai découvert
la classe ils sont femme d'imam ça va
pas qui mais pourquoi mais on était déjà
dans la classe j mais quand qui sauf à
croft christophe koller arrive dans les
amériques il y avait du monde déjà
oui mais en fait c'est une façon de
raconter le monde qui est centrée
sur
la population française qui dans la
convention collective est une population
blanche
et effectivement il faut qu'il y ait des
gens qui questionnent cette façon de
penser en disant on attendait mais on va
pas avancer comme ça effectivement il
faut expliquer ce que c'était l'
esclavage ce que c'était la colonisation
pour comprendre ce qu'est la france
aujourd'hui est donc il y a des gens qui
ont du mal à accepter
ce changement parce qu'en fait ce qui
est très compliqué chez chacun de nous
et c'est accepter le changement changé
de discours changer de façon de dire les
choses et pour que ce changement
advienne il faut qu'il y ait des
personnes de la société civile qui
pousse qui pousse qui pousse et qui
petit à petit emmène au changement et
d'ailleurs il y a eu un changement quand
même parce que ma maman elle a grandi on
lui apprenait que ses ancêtres étaient
des gaulois aux antilles il ya du
progrès
et donc attendez je vais vous montrer
une carte que je montre
que je montre aux enfants dans les
écoles
voyez en fait quand je montre cette
carte il ya un vrai débat sans fin le 10
mai non mais la carte elle à l'envers
ils font la tournée et donc ils
finissent par là mais comme ça après 10
maintenant mais l'écriture est en fait
si juste pour montrer aux enfants que
à force de voir une chose
d'une seule façon fini par croire qu'il
n'ya qu'une façon de la voir j'explique
aux enfants que effectivement la terre
est ronde comme un ballon de foot et
qu'on peut la regarder dans n'importe
quelle direction
et c'est ça le problème
c'est à dire qu'effectivement nous
sommes éduqués à voir l'histoire dans
une seule direction et ont fini par
conditionner la majorité de la
population à penser dans cette direction
donc lorsqu'on leur dit voilà il faut
changer vos regards c'est très compliqué
et effectivement les gens ne savent pas
qu'en règle générale les cas
traditionnel que nous connaissons il ya
l'europe au centre mais l'europe est
agrandie et l'amérique du nord est a
grandi en fait c'est une carte qui est
centré sur l'europe est en fait c'est ça
le problème c'est à dire que dans notre
éducation malheureusement nous sommes
centrés sur la france et on ne comprend
pas que la france est partie du monde et
a toujours fait partie du monde donc
voilà pourquoi il faut aborder certains
sujets mais ce n'est pas que
je dirais l'éducation
nationale
ce matin je suis allé faire une émission
de radio et il y avait un photographe
qui est en train de faire au musée de
l'homme une exposition sur l'histoire de
l'exclavage
et on me demandait de commenter de ces
photos
et je disais m'attendais mais c'est
incroyable quand même c'est à dire que
sur toutes les photos il n'y a que des
noirs mais si on veut parler de
l'histoire de l'exclavage il faudrait
qu'ils des blancs quand même parce que à
peu pour quelque chose exactement
mais si on doit parler de l' esclavage
il quand même parler des personnes de
couleur blanche parce que si l esclavage
aux antilles
c'est avant eux c'est eux avant tout
qu'ils doivent
être questionnés et c'est assez marrant
et le commissaire m'a ya un moment de il
ya un journée ce qui me disait ah ben
oui c'est vrai
c'est juste pour vous dire que parfois
dans l'éducation ont fait pas attention
à certaines choses parce que nous sommes
dans la reproduction et donc il faut
questionner pour que ça puisse changer
et je suis je reste persuadé qu'avec le
temps les choses ont changé les choses
ont évolué
savons peut-être aussi de noirs dans la
conception des programmes scolaires non
bella vous touchez un vrai problème
effectivement il manque des gens qui ont
une autre expérience de l'histoire qui
vont raconter autre chose et qu'ils vont
interpeller voilà pourquoi je pense que
nous devons être réunies peu importe
leur couleur de peau la religion notre
niveau social il faut qu'il y ait des
discussions parce que il faut emmener
une pluralité de vue sur un sujet
et c'est ce qui manque dans nos sociétés
et donc sa touche comment le faire et ce
qu'il faut passer par des quotas est-ce
qu'il faut passer par des lois mais en
tout cas il faut construire 7 7 cette
communion pour qu'on puisse penser
différemment et pour qu'on puisse penser
plus intelligemment je pense
pour rebondir sur cette carte
qu'est ce que vous pensez de la
situation de l'afrique actuellement qui
a un terrain d'expérimentation si bien
pour l'industrie de l'agriculture qui
teste des pesticides des ogm ou
l'industrie pharmaceutique qui sert des
populations comme cobayes
mais est ce que l'afrique n'a
historiquement depuis peut-être cinq
siècles n'a pas toujours été un lieu
d'expérimentation
parce que c'est ça la réalité c'est à
dire que lorsqu'on parle du racisme ce
n'est pas simplement du racisme entre
deux individus
ce n'est pas simplement un système
à l'intérieur d'un pays c'est aussi
comment on gère le monde
et lorsque vous analysez
l'histoire récente et bien l'afrique a
toujours été au centre lorsque vous
parlez de l' esclavage
l'afrique des esclavages atlantique
l'afrique a été au centre on a toujours
construit un discours extrêmement
négatif sur l'afrique pour pouvoir mieux
l'exploiter pour pouvoir exploiter les
sommes dont on avait besoin lorsqu'on
parle de la colonisation c'est
exactement la même chose c'est-à-dire un
moment donné on a besoin de débouchés on
a besoin d'hommes on a besoin de
matières premières donc il fallait
construire un discours en négatif sur
l'afrique et aujourd'hui c'est encore le
cas vous sortez vous poser des questions
aux gens dans la rue et vous leur dites
vous avez dit moi l'image que vous avez
de l'afrique ce sera pas une image
positive mais pourquoi parce qu'on a
besoin de construire cette image
négative pour ne pas comprendre
qu'effectivement l'afrique est au centre
de tout lorsque vous prenez votre
téléphone portable
ok l'afrique est au centre de tout les
guerres qui lie à pour les matières
premières
sont des guerres qui permettent à nous
aujourd'hui occidentaux de vivre comment
nous vivons c'est ça la réalité est donc
effectivement
mouais des gens n'ont pas conscience de
cela et quand vous achetez une bague de
fiançailles avec un diamant dessus vous
avez plusieurs morts sur la conscience
après il y aurait aujourd'hui brochet
pas si c'est plusieurs morts sur la
conscience quand même parce que les gens
ne sont pas au courant mais c'est un
tracé serait intéressant qu'ils sachent
le pourquoi des choses pour convient
aussi bien et ce rapport de domination
explique aussi le rapport entre les
individus
parce que c'est une construction d'un
discours qui voudrait dire que il y
aurait une terre qui ne sert à rien où
il y à la guerre où il ya des sauvages
mais on ne dit pas pourquoi il faut les
traiter de sauvages
parce qu'en fait les vrais sauvages
peut-être que ce ne sont pas eux
l'année dernière on apprenait dans un
documentaire sur france 2 que charles de
gaulle avait exigé qu'on interdise les
tirailleurs sénégalais de défiler lors
de la libération de la même façon que le
père de la gauche républicaine jules
ferry était profondément raciste et
créer colonialiste le père de la droite
française n'était guère mieux
la fin annoncée par mc rondes ces deux
familles politiques les stèles entrevoir
un espoir
un espoir oui parce que nous sommes en
2017 lorsqu'on regarde l'histoire du
racisme du sexisme l'homophobie
on voit qu'il y à des avancées moi je
dis très souvent que mon grand-père et
les en 1908 soixante ou soixante ans
après l'abolition de l'esclavagé ce qu
on al impression qu est ce qu elle va s
est quelque chose de très loin et très
désincarné
mais mon grand-père et les soixante ans
après l'abolition des esclavages ma mère
est née en 1947
donc il y avait la ségrégation aux états
unis avaient la colonisation de la
france sur d'autres pays moi je suis né
en
1972 il y avait l'apartheid en afrique
du sud donc vous voyez que nous sommes
dans une avancée parce que les personnes
qui étaient mis dans une position de
dominant acceptent plus facilement
l'égalité aujourd'hui c'est à dire que
nous les hommes nous acceptons plus
facilement l'égalité aujourd'hui avec
les femmes c'est à dire les hommes et
les femmes les personnes de couleur
blanche acceptent plus facilement
l'égalité avec les autres personnes
d'autres couleurs d'autres couleurs que
hier c'est ça la réalité c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui on voit bien que les
autres sections aussi acceptent le fait
que les personnes homosexuelles et plus
de droits et donc je pense que c'est ça
qui est intéressant c'est à dire que les
années qui viennent de s'écouler
montrent que sur l'homosexualité en tout
cas et sur d'autres sujets c'est
malheureusement pas si simple que ça
mais vous savez c'est jamais simple de
perdre ses avantages parce qu'en fait le
vrai problème du racisme du sexisme de
le mot fille c'est c'est ceux qui sont
dans un avantage et qui ne veulent pas
perdre cet avantage là et c'est pour ça
que je dis qu'il faut parler à ces gens
là
lorsque vous avez le bus ou escales rosa
parce c'est super intéressant quand même
lorsque vous êtes blanc c'est à dire que
vous pouvez arriver à n'importe quel
moment il ya un noir qui va se lever et
donc quand il ya une femme noire qui dit
je ne veux pas me lever ben tout d'un
coup ils comprennent pas et disent
m'attendais qu'est ce que c'est que
cette histoire on a toujours eu
l'habitude lorsque nous arrivons que les
noirs se lève pour ré veulent pas se
lever et en fait c'est il faut éduquer
les personnes à dire oh vous devez
travailler pour l'égalité c'est à dire
que ça vous concerne oui et c'est vous
qui pouvez faire changer les choses et
pour l'homosexualité c'est exactement la
même chose c'est-à-dire qu'il faut
éduquer les personnes à comprendre
pourquoi ils sont homophobes parce que
très souvent ils ne savent pas pourquoi
on les racistes pourquoi les sexistes
mais en fait par habitude c'est un fait
culturel et donc il faut questionner les
conditionnements qu'on va recevoir tout
au long de notre vie
l'évolution de l'antiracisme dévouement
apparu depuis des décennies comme sos
racisme ou bien plus intérieure encore
comme la licra
sont aujourd'hui un de moins en moins
légitime car identifiés comme des
satellites de parti politique et on
pense à la marche des beurs qui
voulaient des droits et des sweats
racines ce qui leur a donné des concerts
gratuits au mouvement plus contemporain
et qui sont beaucoup plus radicaux comme
des indigènes de la république qui
s'organisent en collectif qui montrent
leurs médias et qui sont souvent
construit en opposition à cette ancienne
génération de mouvements antiracistes
pourquoi on assiste à une telle
évolution
tout d'abord
qu'est-ce que c'est l'anti racisme pour
moi l'antiracisme c'est avant tout une
lutte pour l'égalité et la lutte pour
l'égalité n'a pas attendu sos racisme ou
la licra si depuis la nuit des temps
lorsqu'on parle du racisme par exemple
il ya la couleur de la peau mais depuis
toujours il ya eu des hommes et des
femmes qui ont combattu
le racisme la domination moi je suis
entier il ya la culture du marronnage
c'est à dire les esclaves qui s'enfuit
du système esclavagiste
donc moi je pense que nous sommes dans
cette continuité et ce qui est très
important à comprendre c'est qu'il y a
toujours des chocs de génération c'est à
dire que très souvent on a tendance à a
expliqué que dans le passé ils se sont
trompés
parce que oui se sont trompés parce que
nous vivons dans une réalité qui est
autre donc on combat différemment mais
chaque génération a à faire un travail
bien fait mal fait mais c'est eux qui
nous permettent d'aller plus loin et
aujourd'hui effectivement il ya d'autres
stratégies de dénonciation de cette
domination mais c'est toujours le même
discours c'est dénoncer
les inégalités dénoncer les avantages de
certains sur d'autres
on va parler de technologie un instant
donc n'hésitez pas à me demander des
précisions si ce que vous ressentez vous
vous demandez je suis cassista clair je
vais vous commencez par vous parler
d'une entrevue qui s'appelle spa liantes
qui en presse française de high tech
très proche de dirigeants socialistes
comme julien dray ou jean jacques urvoas
ou de personnalités de droite comme
nadine morano et qui vend des solutions
technologiques de gestion du territoire
par la cartographie à des collectivités
locales ça vous permet en tant que
politique d'aborder votre vie votre
département votre région à travers des
cartographies sûr qu'elle va projeter
des informations l'an dernier cette
entreprise s'est fait pincer par le
canard enchaîné
elle proposait des cartographies
ethnique du territoire fait les
politiques gérer leur territoire dans
une approche et concentrique c'est légal
comme dirait fillon mais est ce que
c'est vraiment en adéquation avec les
valeurs de la république
c'est çà me parait ça me paraît
dangereux surtout
si je dirais que ça fait presque peur
fait effectivement c'est à dire que
[Musique]
pour rester au pouvoir on est capable de
faire
des choses un peu qui serait contre
productif pour le bien vivre ensemble
c'est à dire si on tient un discours
bien précis qui flatte certaines
personnes moi ça me paraît ça me paraît
extrêmement dangereux ça sera
précisément à ça oui oui j'avais compris
ça tu mets ça me paraît ouais ouais ça
me paraît très très grave tout ça donc
c'est très bien de dénoncer d'ailleurs
regardez je ne savais même pas
c'est de la techno un peu pointu et le
problème de ce genre de techno c'est
qu'elle a du mal à arriver aux oreilles
du grand public
c'était technologie carbure à base de ce
qu'on appelle le big data
typiquement à partir d'un nom de famille
on peut en déduire avec une très forte
probabilité une origine ethnique
pas suffisant pour faire du fichage
ethnique mais largement suffisant pour
faire de la statistique ethnique
et on utilise aussi dans le cadre
d'alliances les fichiers électoraux
qu'on peut acquérir pour une semaine
absolument modique et qui renseigne sur
le lieu de naissance des électeurs à
l'heure où il ya de nombreux rapports
qui annoncent l'imminence d'un
terrorisme d'extrême droite là encore
c'est légal mais comme dirait ferrand
mais est ce que c'est bien sérieux de
laisser de telles données personnelles
quasiment à libre disposition
ça c'est évident que c'est pas sérieux
du tout surtout que de l'autre côté on
nous explique c'est pas une bonne chose
de faire des quotas c'est pas une bonne
chose
[Musique]
de faire des fichiers ethniques donc ça
me paraît ouais ça me paraît surréaliste
on est encore dans la schizophrénie
politique on est très souvent je pense
que les politiques malheureusement je
veux pas dire tous mais parfois pour
arriver à leurs fins sont capables de
tout voir dupire quoi vous avez entendu
parler du fichier unique décidé très
récemment par bernard cazeneuve qui
fiche tous les tous les résidents
français non
derrière ce fichier unique qui a la même
société qui est en 1941 a été mandatée
par le régime de vichy pour faire le
fichier juif ça vous inspire quoi
j'ai l'impression que vous n'êtes pas
sérieux mais je sais que vous êtes
sérieux
et
sait dans quel but le fichier unique
fichier la population française c'est
très à la mode en ce moment
mais je pense que way s'est passé
malheureusement c'est pas que les
politiques qui pensent à ça c'est ça qui
est très grave c'est à dire que
plus ça va aller plus on sera fiché plus
on saura ce qu'on aime ce qu'on n'aime
pas et plus on pourra contrôler on
pourra vous contrôlez c'est ça qui est
grave d'ailleurs je pense que ç'a
toujours été la volonté des politiques
c'est à dire
être au plus près pour savoir et pour
anticiper pour contrôler les gens plus
facilement et c'est extrêmement c'est
extrêmement grave qu'on puisse se
laisser faire
je vous parlais de notre technologie qui
est celle ci est américain cette peur là
quand même c'est très flippant les
technologies quand on regarde vraiment
le côté obscur de la force cette fois ci
je vous parlais de pallanne tiers c'est
infiniment plus flippant pas mentir
c'est une société américaine gigantesque
cap pour principal client des gens comme
la nes à la cia web biya et qui est
accusé par nombreuses personnalités de
la silicon valley de constituer un
fichier musulmans aux etats-unis
accessoirement le fondateur de palerme
et le conseiller au numérique de donald
trump
très récemment
la des séries les services de
renseignement français rangements
intérieurs français qui vous avait dû en
entendre parler surveille la population
française quasiment dans son ensemble on
confiait la gestion de leurs données de
surveillance de la population française
à cette même société palencia est ce
qu'on est en train de préparer une
heures sombres de notre histoire comme
on le dit pudiquement
ça
ouais mais attendez
moi je pense que
depuis toujours
ceux qui veulent le pouvoir
doivent contrôler l'intimité des gens
c'est ce que je pense de la religion
c'est à dire dans la distance de la
religion ce contrôle l'intimité
et pour moi c'est la même démarche c'est
à dire contrôler
ce que vous allez faire
et tout savoir
parce que c'est encore une fois la
meilleure façon de vous orienter et vous
emmener dans la direction que certains
vont vouloir vous emmener parce que
c'est comme oui effectivement la
politique c'est à dire que lorsqu'on
utilise les médias pour
répéter répéter sans cesse des choses
pour que les gens finissent par croire
que c'est vrai sauf que là ça me paraît
extrêmement dangereux parce que j'ai
l'impression qu'il faut trouver
quelque chose pour contrer cela parce
qu'on a toujours essayé dans les
sociétés de trouver comment contrer ceux
qui veulent contrôler la société et là
j'ai l'impression que c'est extrêmement
compliqué quand même si on arrive à ça
c'est un sport d'élite réservé aux
hackers voilà donc à très peu très peu
c'est clair que la population générale
ne peut pas échapper à ce type de
surveillance
d'autant plus que la surveillance va de
google à la nsa en passant par les
services français les frontières sont
extrêmement poreuse entre surveillance
privée à des fins marketing et
surveillance étatique à des fins
politiques on va écouter ce qu'on peut
espérer c'est qu'ils aient des hackers
de grande qualité pour essayer de
contrecarrer tous tous ces projets parce
que c'est pas anodin de ses projets
voilà
on
va parler un peu foot alors pas du tout
sous un angle technique
commencer par cette question les
empereurs romains prenez un soin fou à
donner au peuple du pain et des jeux
pour abrutir la population est-ce qu'on
a réellement évolué depuis ou est ce que
le foot a tout simplement remplacer les
combats de gladiateurs et le rmi le pain
promis par ge de césar
nous sommes dans la même logique c'est à
dire qu'effectivement il faut amuser le
peuple
il faut amuser le peuple
parce que effectivement nous pensent à
autre chose nous sommes dans l'émotion
total
mais ça marche parce que aussi il y à
des personnes qui gagnent de l'argent
c'est à dire que le foot on va prendre
le foot parce que c'est le sport numéro
un au monde ça marche parce que il y à
des boîtes qui se font beaucoup d'argent
parce qu'ils font vendre des publicités
il est à un moment où les gens sont dans
l'émotion total c'est pour ça que ça
marche le fouta il faut pas être il faut
pas être dupe aussi le foot raconte mais
raconte la société dans laquelle on vit
tout simplement
qui au final n'a pas vraiment évolué
depuis les romains non ça a évolué quand
même recevoir
mais c'est la même logique c'est la même
logique c'est à dire qu' effectivement
il faut voir comment les politiques
parfois arrivent à instrumentaliser le
sport
et notamment dans les pays pauvres
donc c'est toujours la même logique oui
effectivement le sport permet justement
de faire en sorte que les gens
pensent un peu moins voilà mais en même
temps ce qu'il faut dire aussi c'est que
l'être humain nous sommes des êtres
d'émotion donc il faut aussi s'amuser il
faut aussi aller vers des choses où on
aura que de l'émotion pure parce que le
footsie quand vous êtes spectateur c'est
ça vous est pris par l'émotion la
victoire la défaite
mais c'est pour cela qu'il faut toujours
réfléchir
à ce qu'il ya derrière le sport et ne
pas prendre
argent comptant dix ans c'est magnifique
parce que le foot raconte vraiment la
société par exemple je trouve que ce que
raconte le foot aujourd'hui
c'est le déplacement
le déplacement de l'économie c'est à
dire que pendant très longtemps
le centre était en europe quand
monétaire l'argent ou ceux aux états
unis
aujourd'hui si vous regardez le foot
vous allez voir que c'est assez
incroyable que par exemple qu'un club
comme le milan ac
vous savez à qui appartient le menacer
non
le kata non
à la chine
une entreprise chinoise okay c'est super
intéressant c'est à dire qu'on voit
comment en fait il ya eu un déplacement
parce que personne peut imaginer enfin
il y a dix ans ou quinze ans personne
pourrait imaginer que le milan ac soit
racheté par une entreprise chinoise
et la france est exactement la même
chose c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui le
club le plus puissant
c'est le paris saint germain et sa
partie au qatar il y a vingt ans
personne n'aurait pensé ça aussi en y
temps je crois que en angleterre il ya
des clubs qui appartiennent à des
entreprises qui viennent de malaisie
je retrouve que le foot raconte
énormément de choses qu'on prend le
temps d'analyser le foot on comprend
beaucoup de choses sur la société donc
effectivement il ya l'amusement mais il
ya aussi autre chose et je ne sais pas
si jamais autant de roms
si les les jeux raconter tout ça la
mondialisation et aux autres ce que
raconte le foot c'est l'argent fou et
l'évasion fiscale l'argent et la fifa
est ce que vous avez vous vu ou entendu
des responsables parler ouvertement de
la version financière non mais attendez
soyons sérieux penser que les dirigeants
font parler d'eux ce moment les joueurs
de malversations donc ça se passe pas
comme ça mais encore une fois lorsque
vous parlez de ces problématiques liées
à l'argent mais c'est ce qui se passe à
des niveaux plus élevés que le foot mais
très souvent on focalise sur le foot en
essayant de faire croire
que justement il n'y a que dans le
football ça se passerait non attendez il
ya des grandes entreprises qui sont en
europe qui sont en france qui ne paient
pas leurs impôts en france ça on a des
révélations tous les bruits non mais oui
c'est ça que je veux dire c'est à dire
que les sommes qui sont dans le foot est
beaucoup moindre que lorsqu'on analyse
autour de nous mais très souvent on a
tendance à regarder ta vu ce qu'il ya
dans le foot mais il ya des gens qui
vont boire des coups dans dans des
enseignes très connu et ben c'est en
scène très connus ne paient pas leurs
impôts aussi parce qu'ils font des
montages financiers et lorsqu'on analyse
aussi par exemple ce qui se passe au
niveau de la bourse les spéculations
c'est exactement la même chose et
parfois les pays sont ils sont courants
par exemple aux états unis qui font la
chasse mais il ya
celle de leur nom ok
donc ça aussi il faut le dire est que
les gens le sachent mais comme la
plupart des gens s'intéressent au foot
on essaie de faire croire que dans le
foot il y aurait tous ces problèmes et
ce serait cantonné au foot et donc en
fait les gens ne restent ne raisonne pas
sûr en dehors du foot et peut-être qui
si ils résonnait en dehors du foot
peut-être qu'ils verraient que
effectivement mais ça les desserts
beaucoup plus
que ce ce qui passe dans le foot c'est
sur ok
à ma connaissance mais elle est limitée
pour le foot il ya aucun dirigeant noir
dans les instances dirigeantes du
football pourquoi
ouais je crois que là c'est du 100% je
crois de personnes proches c'est quand
même assez ahurissant comment c'est
particulièrement intéressant hamas est
ahurissant oui c'est très intéressant et
pourquoi
alors tout d'abord il faut savoir que
pour que vous puissiez penser que c'est
possible il faut qu'il y ait déjà
quelqu'un qui vous disent tiens c'est
possible de faire
c'est ça le danger c'est pour ça qu'il
faut qu'ils aient de la mixité est
effectivement au foot il y a beaucoup de
joueurs noirs il ya très peu
d'entraîneurs noir aussi il ya très peu
de dirigeants enfin il ya très peu
d'entraîneurs noir attention lorsqu'on
parle du racisme c'est toujours pareil
c'est à dire que plus vous allez
regarder tout temps au moins il ya de
mixité de couleur de peau mais si vous
allez regarder tout en bas si vous allez
dans la région parisienne et regarder
sur les terrains de foot qui entraîne
les enfants la grande majorité ce ton
des jeunes noirs des jeunes de type
maghrébin pension c'est à dire que ce
qui est dérangeant dans le racisme c'est
lorsque vous voulez atteindre le niveau
élevé tant que vous êtes en bas ok
d'accord vous accepte mais temps quand
vous allez en haut c'est un peu
compliqué d'ailleurs pensant au foot le
président de
de la ligue d'île de france
je crois que c'est un monsieur qui
s'appelle sandjak
d'origine maghrébine il ya encore
quelques exceptions ouais je crois mais
ça reste de leurs de l'exception oui oui
ça reste de leurs de l'exception et ce
qui est très important c'est pouvoir le
dire mais vous savez très souvent quand
vous dites ces choses là les gens ne
veulent pas écouter et vous ils vous
font passer pour un méchant et ça aussi
c'est une stratégie pour ne pas en
parler donc c'est pour ça qu'il faut
continuer à en parler des noms c'est
surtout en tout cas déranger les gens
pour qu'ils puissent regarder autour
d'eux et se dire ouais c'est vrai
peut-être qu'il faudrait qu'on change
mais au foot c'est pas gagné parce que
il n'ya pas longtemps certains voulaient
faire des quotas
en disant qu'il y avait trop de jeunes
oies de jeunes de musulmans nés dans les
centres de formation
voilà ce qui est très grave c'est que ce
monsieur en question
n'a pas été renvoyé de la fédération
française aujourd'hui il n'y est plus
parce que je crois qu'il a la retraite
mais à l'époque cap a été renvoyé c'est
très léger les les actions pour lutter
contre le racisme dans le milieu du foot
pour ma part oui je trouve ça très léger
mais c'est bien que ça existe parce
qu'il fut un temps ça n'existait pas
donc c'est très bien de qui est des
joueurs importants qui le dit ce qui est
des campagnes c'est pour ça que je vous
dis c'est à dire que les choses avancent
il faut simplement essayer que les
provoquer pour que ça avance encore plus
vite je raconte ce qui s'est passé il
n'y a pas très longtemps en italie
un joueur de foot qui s'appelle muntari
se fait insulter
sur sa couleur de peau donc il va voir
l'arbitré en disant m'attendais faut
arrêter match est un scandale larbitre
lui met un carton jaune
et il retourne voir l'arbitré dit mais
attendez c'est scandaleux il faut
arrêter match et l'arbitré n'arrête pas
le match et lui décident de partir larbi
tu m'as carton rouge
c'est super intéressant quand même et
tout d'un coup le joueur noir est
expulsé le match continue
et c'est ce qu'il faut dénoncer et moi
c'est ce que j'essaye de dénoncer et moi
je dis voilà
qui peut faire évoluer les choses
c'est pas mon mari parce que très
souvent les journalistes vont voir le
joueur noir comme c'était mon cas quand
j'étais en dix ans qu'est ce qu'on peut
faire ben moi je réponds on ne peut rien
faire nous mais par contre les joueurs
blancs qui ne subissent pas le racisme
peut faire les choses
en quittant le terrain les rues de
quitter le terrain les gens dans les
tribunes
blanc peut faire des choses dont vous
voyez bien que c'est pas moi qui peut
changer des choses
et c'est pour ça que j'ai dit très
souvent ce sont les personnes qui ne
sont pas discriminer qui peuvent changer
les choses
mais il faut prendre conscience de ça
la politique de la ville ce résultat est
là comme black blanc beur mêlée de foot
et de hip hop le on se souvient du match
france algérie en 2001 est-ce que c'est
pas le symbole de l'échec delà de cette
politique anti racisme n'est depuis le
début des années 80
c'est évident que si vous donnez
simplement aux jeunes le hip-hop et le
foot
c'est trop peu mais la réalité n'est pas
toujours celle là quand même c'est à
dire que moi je rencontre beaucoup de
profs beaucoup de personnes
d'associations qui travaille aussi avec
les enfants en les emmenant
au théâtre dans les musées par exemple
moi je suis le parrain de demos je ne
sais pas si vous connaissez des mots ce
nom je ne pourrais pas vous dire
exactement
que signifie demos mais en fait c'est la
philharmonie de paris qui met à
disposition des instruments et des profs
pour
apprendre aux enfants défavorisés
un instrument pour faire de la musique
classique et il y a
de mémoire je ne sais pas exactement
combien de
d'orchestre en france et donc il ya des
gens qui font des choses quand même très
très très bien ça s'est il faut il faut
le répéter quand même parce que sinon on
va tomber dans la caricature où il ya
que du hip hop et que du foot et c'est
pas c'est pas vrai parce que comme je
suis un mondial il ya plein d'autres
nous il ya théâtre voilà et ça c'est
très important
de le dire parce que sinon on pourrait
penser que les choses n'avancent pas
c'est pour cela je dis que les choses
avancent petitement mais sûrement parce
que ça va assez vite mais ça ne va
jamais assez vite mais encore une fois
vous êtes confrontés à des habitudes
c'est ça le problème il ya des habitudes
que les gens ne veulent pas changer
ils se disent eux ne sont pas à leur
place par exemple moi j'ai g j'ai
accepté d'être le parrain de demos
pourquoi parce que lorsque j'étais
enfant en classe de cm2 tous les
vendredis soirs
enfin le vendredi après midi notre prof
durant la dernière heure novitec de la
musique classique et moi j'adorais ça
mais j'étais incapable de le dire aux
autres
pourquoi voyez bien que parfois on se
met des freins soi même et par habitude
je dise je me disais tiens je suis d'une
cité je peux pas dire aux autres que
j'aime la musique classique mais
peut-être que dans la classe y en avait
plein comme moi et on a on a n'arrivait
pas s'avouer qu'on aimait la musique
classique c'est triste donc c'est pour
ça qu'à un moment donné il faut changer
nos habitudes mais quand je parle de
vaud abrite c'est tout le monde et peu
importe la couleur de peau peu importe
les religions parce que parfois on nous
sommes enfermés dans nos habitudes dans
des catégories et en fait il faut par
l'éducation ouvrir ses champs pour dire
aux enfants ayez confiance en vous à
aller aussi vers des choses qui vous
paraissent aujourd'hui impossible mais
que vous pouvez prendre et il faut aider
ces enfants là aussi à avoir une bonne
estime de même en se disant tout et pour
moi comme il faut aider d'autres enfants
qui se pensent supérieur parce qu'ils
sont supérieures et qui se disent ben ça
c'est pas pour eux
ça c'est pour moi parce qu'en fait très
souvent c'est l'habitude du mépris
mépris de soi mépris des autres
jusqu'où êtes vous prêt à aller pour
défendre vos valeurs à la mort
c'est une réponse qui est sorti tout ça
elle est gravé pour l'éternité
dont on va conclure par une tradition
chez centerview est-ce que vous pouvez
nous donner un conseil pour les jeunes
générations afin qu'on puisse avancer
ensemble
pour moi ce qui est essentiel chez
à développer chez les plus jeunes c'est
avoir une bonne estime de soi parce que
lorsque vous avez une bonne estime de
vous vous n'avez pas besoin d'écraser
les autres pour exister
et c'est estime de soi en fait se
cultive dans la connaissance de soi même
donc la connaissance de l'histoire
dans la connaissance de l'histoire
familiale
mondiale et surtout
qu'on puisse à la fin développer cette
éducation qui va nous permettre de nous
percevoir avant tout comme des êtres
humains
parce qu'en fait c'est ça le piège
l'autre il est noir il est musulman
l'autre qu'il est juif c'est une fille
c'est un homosexuel
c'est en afrique c'est un européen et je
pense qu'en fait on se rend pas compte
mais en nous enfermant dans des
catégories eh bien on ne se perçoit pas
comme il faudrait et en accepte
certaines choses par exemple un truc
tout bête je me dis quand même comment
se fait-il que on ne parle pas par
exemple de
les guerres qu'il y a au zaïre par
exemple
comment se fait-il qu'en même que nous
sommes dans un pays de liberté de la
presse
depuis des années des années il y a des
gens qui se font tuer dans des zones
justement où il y a une vraie lutte pour
les matières premières et on n'en parle
pas
pourquoi on ne parle pas parce que ce
sont des africains je n'arrive pas y
croire quand pour pouvoir acheter nos
téléphones portables tranquillement
peut-être mais je n'arrive pas assez et
moi je pense que lorsque vous percevez
l'autre comme vous eh ben c'est plus
facile à le défendre
donc c'est ça je pense
thuram avant de conclure je vais vous
passez le bonjour de josé soares et
terminer en vous remerciant d'être venu
nous voir assez curieux écoutez merci à
vous de m'avoir invité
vous faites un peu peur quand même parce
que en vous écoutant sur les nouvelles
technologies à ça me ça me déstabilise
quand même j'en ai bien d'autres en
réserve c'est vrai bon pas tout de suite
alors nous ne fait pas peur ok une lente
url merci merci à vous
[Musique]